in a week of drama a day of Jeopardy
the UK now facing what looks
increasingly like a financial crisis
with the bank of England taking
extraordinary steps to secure the
plumbing of the economic system we don't
normally spend much time talking about
long-dated government debt for good
reason it's pretty dull and it's dull
because this is where Pension funds put
their money but over the course of the
past few days it has been anything but
dull since the chancellor statement on
Friday there's been a chain reaction
running through that market which the
bank has detected was causing a run
Dynamic a kind of wholesale version of
what happened to Northern Rock so they
work through the night and came up with
an unprecedented package
that intervention a commitment to buy as
many bonds as it took to stabilize the
market Pension funds were suddenly faced
with the need to raise collateral money
that they needed to pay uh the the
companies that they had taken out
contracts with on an immediate basis so
they were actually adding to the vicious
spiral by selling guilts in the market
as well which then made prices go uh
even lower
and that itself created problems for
other Pension funds who then started to
have to sell and I think that's what the
bank of England was trying to stem with
its actions today
the story becomes clear when you look at
one of those assets this is one of
Britain's long-dated bonds look at how
its price fell in recent days causing
that spiral for many funds then came the
bank's intervention and since then the
price has begun to recover
but a crisis in Britain's pension system
is a crisis for the whole financial
system the chancellor meeting today with
bank Executives in an effort to reassure
the city
and ministers still defiant in the face
of Market turmoil for a lot of people
they're looking at what's happening in
financial markets and they see a storm
and they see a storm that started with
that fiscal statement last Friday do you
not take responsibility for that no we
we both know that we're seeing the same
impacts of Putin's war in Ukraine
cascading through things like the cost
of energy some of the supply side
implications of that and that's
impacting every major economy and just
the same every major economy you're
seeing interest rates going up as well
so as as we're not to the same degree as
in the UK
every major economy is dealing with
exactly these same issues at the heart
of this all is a deep tension and one
that is now playing out in financial
markets on one part of town the
chancellor has a stated growth objective
of two and a half percent on the other
part of town the bank of England's own
view is that the growth potential of the
UK economy is about one percent below
that that tension is now what we're
seeing being resolved in financial
markets because they're saying well if
if the government wants to go for two
and a half percent or the chancellor
does
that is going to mean the interest rates
are going to have to rise in a way
that's going to defeat the objective for
two and a half percent
it is hard to think of any other budget
which has caused quite such chaos a
currency plunge followed by a mortgage
Spike and now a threat to the very
Plumbing that sits beneath our economy
what happens next is anyone's guess